my entire life I've been
treated quite bad I feel I feel really
alone and I felt like I was going to
search YouTube for people with the same
issue as me and that is being really
unattractive and I've been having lots
of issues with that cuz every video I
come across is with a really attractive
or normal person and they have no idea
there was this time when I had a date
with a girl and I stood on the train on
the train station and I looked for her
for 2 hours before I was like okay she
gave up and then I went home and then
she wrote that when she saw me I was so
ugly she didn't have the encouragement
to talk to me that was a girl that
treated me so badly and was just using
me she did every she called me ugly she
forced me to walk 5 to 10 m behind her
she'd never hold my hand she never
kissed me it was not a good relationship
she never cared about me she was always
angry aggressive and for the first half
year she didn't really want to be in an
actual relationship with me she just
wanted to be with me we had then she
started calling me and being like you
should take me back
cuz you are unlovable I remember those
words so clearly you are unlovable hey
and welcome to another blog it well it's
been a while since we've done a Blog a
lot of things have happened I'm here
with my wife Julie we are married with
my
husband I love saying it though I love
like all the time my my husband and my
wife every single time all right get
over
it was
happy you don't have have to repeat it
every five seconds we know you happy I'm
happy for you what do you
mean happy for you all
right don't need to rub it in the face
of people all right we get it it's your
wife your husband husband wife wife
husband husband what we get it what you
want to say
sayy what why you being a hater I cannot
be a hater yeah you're hating really
hard that's crazy hating they just came
off third honeymoon come like whenever
someone is hating it's often time
because they don't have that thing I
have it no they have it and still be
hating some people are miserable inside
some people are married and they're
hating on other marri I like I just
don't like it's not a question of hating
not everything is hating not not every
time someone disagrees with something or
or something like it's like PDA I don't
like public display affection all right
I like when people just smooshing
everything and stuff it's not me hating
on them it's me not wanted to see that
I don't like that I don't hate on
them I don't want to see that in public
that's not something that I like it
makes me cringe when you say I'm with my
wife I that's my wife my wife over here
right that makes me cringe because I'm
like yeah I got it the first the first
time you said it it's not a hate thing
it's just a yo you don't have to repeat
it that much I heard you the first time
you said it they just got married they
can't be excited right after just
getting married sure okay so there's not
context which someone you just like all
right you know this is their moment if
it's 10 years in and they still get
excit fine they just got me yeah so just
be excited so repeating it is not
necessary that's just me okay that's
that's my wife my wife my wife my wife
even when you get like a for new car
that's my new car my new whip that's my
whip right there that's my No get on
with it it's not a question of Love or
Whatever what not or it's any it's with
anything that's me the first five second
that's just saying the thing I was like
yeah okay what is it that you want to
tell me you're not going to stay here
saying tell me that it's your wife cuz I
I know you got other things that you
want us to say you want to say so say
that get on with it that's it it's not I
don't think it's hating if you think it
is then it is then then okay all right
love in the positive energy let's keep
going yes a lot of things have happened
[Music]
lately home tour time we have moved and
we are quite well settled so we're going
to show up our new place and how we've
decorated it and all that this is how it
looks in
general so for those of you who don't
know this person is we covered a video
about him where basically he couldn't
find everybody and just said everybody
was repulsed by him and uh he just had a
lot of bad dating experiences I think it
was uh being ugly his experience and he
talked about the crazy ofal rejections
how women would tell him to walk behind
him because they don't want to see me
sink beside him my entire life I've been
treated quite bad I feel I feel really
alone and I felt like I was going to
search YouTube for people with the same
issue as me writing with people who had
it difficult who were
sad and like who didn't have it
easy
and that's when I first met the first
girl in my life
that wanted to be with me and I spent
seven years with that girl and I regret
it very much we were just friends it was
chill she was actually a terrible human
being that's some up I know
a lot of people were just being like
yeah you ugly other people are trying to
send words of encouragement so this
guy's channel it's called never give up
uh and yeah you know you know you said
it's very demoralizing looking this way
and trying to date and you know a few
years later the dude's married yeah he
got his thing going on happy for him
that's what's up so he turned it around
and switched it up and you know
sometimes we we we don't be showing love
to people when they do it and they turn
it around so I was like you know what I
thought it was a good story I ended up
messaging him asked him if you had
anything you wanted to say on the topic
or anything you felt he said L he said
everyone's situation is different so I
don't know how much I could really say
but you know kind of like my username
just never give up and I was like that
was a pretty good message I was thinking
about interviewing for this but I don't
think like I could understand his his
his situation and how bad it is and the
thing is that in the previous video he
was brutally honest about what he was
going on and like I could yeah dude I
get what you mean man it's stuff out
there it is not easy but the fact that
you're able to find someone and stuff
that's cool that's mad cool that's dope
doesn't mean that anybody's gonna find
that but yo never give up that's a great
message and that's great man so what did
you mean before that what you mean that
not anybody's going to get find that
because even even with his not even
having his predicament of looks and
stuff like that I don't think that every
everybody's going to find someone so it
it could be very hard for some people
you know what I mean but you know it's
always good to not lose hope it's it's a
good thing not to lose hope and just you
know you don't know you don't know
what's out there for
you at same same token who am I to say
that nobody's going to find something
maybe you know maybe there is your
someone out there I wouldn't know just
like you know I don't I don't know I
mean there's already people dying alone
today so the idea that there's going to
be more in the future is not an insane
thing to say it just shows you despite
all the setbacks that he as an
individual has not rich not goodlooking
you know not necessar the most
charismatic individual in the world but
you know what staying persistent and
trying and trying to improve himself he
ended up finding somebody who was a
match for him so you know that just
shows you everybody can't not everybody
will now why you can't is a variety of
reasons some people it's circumstantial
but a lot of people it's their own
self-inflicted wounds own expectations
for life or maybe what they want to have
a partnership just doesn't really exist
in reality why I like his message is
because sometimes you feel like there's
nobody for you when you lose hope and
stuff like that and whenever you go on
date you sabotage yourself because your
mindset is not there you already think
that well there's nobody going to be
able I'm never going to be able to meet
someone so if you go out there with that
mentality you might sabotage yourself
even more than you think you know ah
well anyways that person is not going to
like me or that going going there with
that mindset is not going to help you
get anything and achieve anything or
having a relationship or being appealing
to someone nobody wants to be with a de
Downer or something like that someone
that just looks so much down on
themselves and have a negative outlook
on live so or someone who shits on you
when you're excited about something no
no no that's not the same thing I'm
on somebody else I'm try to
make something out something
thing that's not
that it's just yo get on to the
point the lovey the care lovey
you got your old man gripy it's just yo
when when when I see high comes I'm like
yeah you love each other but get the
out of my face I'm sorry that irks
me but I'm happy for them that's that's
what's up I think people got a grace
period you know what I mean they want to
be like that after their honeymoon I get
it it's you it's like every every person
I know right when they just start dating
somebody they get a little butterfly
look in their face they start talking
about their partner it's almost
disgusting but you understand it's fresh
I'm like you know what go live your
little happy moment I can't be separated
from I got go ahead you know and then if
you're like that 3 years in I'm like now
you annoy me but initially it's okay you
there's no even initial period n you
annoy me from from the jump yeah you
annoy me from the jump it's not I'm
excited to call someone you know some
people look for this person to be their
wife their whole life they want they
want to find somebody get that person
that person they cuz you is not like
that for you you didn't have that
struggle cuz you kind of met your person
when you was like 16 17 that's not the
point that is the point because when you
hold when when somebody wants something
for so long when they get it the
excitement for them could be a big thing
especially Point that's not the point
you're missing the point okay go ahead
the point is not so much the fact of
wanting to I am not someone that is a
demonstrative person
at from the jump has nothing to do with
wanting something so bad there's some
stuff that I've wanted for so bad and
for so long that I have now I don't be
like yeah this I don't I don't show it
like that that's very personal to me the
way I feel so it's not a question of
whether you want something for so long
and you have to oh so now you're you're
happy to It's not that it's whether you
show it or you don't some things keep
keep it to yourself or or say it but but
when you rub it in rub it in and I'm
waiting for you to give me information
but you still at the first part I'm like
hey you're occupying my time right now
that's just that's just what it is it
has nothing to do with the fact that I'm
blaming someone that want something for
so long okay you're missing the point
okay I'm missing the point I'm sorry
anything else you want to say on this
topic n all right well glad we could
leave it on such a positive note uh
congratulations on your marriage is all
I wanted to say congrats and uh go enjoy
your wife and say it as many times as
you want don't sit around
pre God damn